CHET HAASE: Hi.
I'm Chet Haase, an engineer in
the Android Team at Google.
I work on graphics and
animation stuff.
And today I wanted to talk about
the topics of bitmaps.
In particular, I want to talk
about bitmaps and garbage.
First, a history lesson
might help.
Prior to the 3.0 release, we
managed bitmap memory at the
native level.
The VM knew about it, but it
really didn't manage it, and
you, in your application, were
responsible for calling a
recycle to very actively
manage that.
When you're done with bitmap,
you call recycle.
That gets rid of the memory.
Otherwise, you may run out of
enough native memory to
allocate another bitmap.
So this was a very careful thing
that applications needed
to manage very tightly.
We decided that it would be a
little bit better for everyone
if we actually managed
that for you.
And we brought the bitmap memory
back into the VM along
with the rest of the
memory that the
garbage collector manages.
So now when you allocate
memory for a bitmap, we
allocate it on the virtual
machine heap.
And then we know when references
to that memory are
gone so that we can collect
it appropriately.
In particular, when a reference
to a large bitmap
goes away and you want to
allocate another bitmap, then
we can see that, well, there's
no reference to
this other one there.
We can collect it in order to
make room for the new one that
needs to come into the
heap at that time.
So all of this is great.
Except that it gets into
situations where maybe the GC
is going to be triggered more
than it was before, because
you're not managing your
own memory manually.
Instead we're managing
that memory for you.
And we manage memory by having
the garbage collector kick in
and collect things
when it needs to.
If there's not a memory in the
heap, we'll collect stuff that
needs to be collected, including
large bitmaps.
Now the trick to this is that
large amounts of memory can be
more expensive to collect.
And large heaps are more
expensive to collect.
So if there's large pieces
of memory due to bitmaps
constantly churning through the
system, then we're going
to be collecting memory
for them a lot, right?
If you're constantly, like
on every frame--
I saw an application like this
recently, where on every frame
of every animation they were
loading a new bitmap and
getting rid of the old one.
And in the old system, they
would actively manage this and
call recycle, and the other one
would be loaded in place.
And life was good.
But as of 3.0, that meant that
the old one was on the heap.
The new one wanted to
be on the heap.
There wasn't enough room
for the both of them.
And so it needed to collect
from the first one.
Relatively expensive garbage
collection to then load in the
second one.
Next frame around, same thing.
Needs to collect the old
one to make enough
room for the new one.
Now that's a reality of dealing
with memory management
and garbage collectors.
And it's decent enough.
But there's actually a really
good way that you can work
around that problem.
And in particular, if you're
working with bitmaps that are
exactly the same size, which
this particular application
was, then you can actually
reuse bitmaps.
So you can have one bitmap that
everything gets loaded
into along the way and save
yourself some serious garbage
collection and performance
along the way.
So let's take a look
at a quick demo.
I call this demo Bitmap
Allocation.
And it's a picture viewer.
I have some pictures that I've
loaded up in the background.
And we can click through these
and see these other images.
And each one of these images is
getting loaded on the fly
as we go through that just for
the purposes of this demo.
And then I print out the number
of milliseconds that it
took to load each of these
images up at the top.
So these loads took 290,
326, 304, 340, 320.
So a little non-deterministic
based on what else is going on
in the system.
And how long GCs took
and stuff like that.
Now if we reuse the bitmap,
then, again, this is a little
bit hard to see, because
the numbers can be
a little bit erratic.
But what I see in runs that I've
done, at least on other
devices, is a savings of, in
general, about 10% to 20%,
which is not bad.
If you're talking about 300
milliseconds in a frame,
saving 30 milliseconds
is a big deal.
Now ideally you'd actually
find a better way to load
these images than loading them
on the fly when you're ready
to draw them.
That's not the best way
to go about it.
But the point of this demo is
more to show the raw amount of
time that it might take
to load these things.
And a lot of that is the
garbage collection.
So let's take a quick look.
Before we look at the code we
can take a look at a log that
I ran right before this where
I was seeing what happened
before and after I checked
that little box that said
Reuse the Bitmap.
And here's what we get.
Oh, let's see.
Here's what we got before
I checked the box.
Is nothing.
This was the output.
Not the GC output above, but
this output here is what we
saw when we reused the bitmap.
But when we're not reusing the
bitmap, this is what we see.
On every frame we're incurring
potentially very expensive
garbage collection.
Some of that runs in parallel.
But we still have pauses of 21
milliseconds for Alex, 3
milliseconds here, 12
milliseconds there.
If you imagine that a 60-frame
per second application only
has 16 milliseconds in order
to draw each frame, these
numbers are huge.
You really want to avoid
them if you can.
So how do we do that?
We use Bitmap Factory Options.
So let's go in here.
Take a look at the code.
This is the bitmap
application code.
And here we have the check box
that determines whether we are
actually going to
do reuse or not.
And in here we're going to
create our bitmap that gets
reused on the fly.
So first of all we're going to
decode the initial image that
we start with.
This application does assume
that all the bitmaps
are the same size.
And this is a restriction with
reusing the bitmaps with this
API, is that it will only work
for bitmaps of the same size.
So we get the size of
the initial bitmap.
And we get only the size.
We don't force it to actually
load that bitmap yet by using
the inJust Decode
Bounds Options.
And that will return the width
and the height that we can
then use in our Create
Bitmap Call.
So we use the width and the
height that we need to sort of
get this sandbox we're going to
load all these things into.
Then we reset that flag.
And we set the inBitmap Flag.
And that is the new API that was
introduced in 3.0 at the
same time as the other
change to the memory
management of bitmaps.
We set that equal to
this sandbox bitmap
that we've just created.
And then we set the inSample
Size to 1.
And this is a necessary and
unfortunate bug that got fixed
in a recent release where if
you didn't set the sample
size, it wouldn't do
the right thing.
So you do need to set it to
what would be the default
option, inSample Size of 1.
And then we decode
the resource.
And away we go.
So now we're in our
Click Listener.
Every time you click on the
image, we're going to load in
the next image.
And we're either going
to reuse that
bitmap or we're not.
So if the check box is checked,
we're going to reuse
the bitmap.
And we're going to do that by
saying the bitmap options
equals these options that we've
created above, which has
this inBitmap Parameter set
in it, which tells--
it's a trigger to the code to
say, OK, this is the sandbox
where I'm going to actually
load this new bitmap into.
And so we set the inBitmap
Flag there.
And then I was just issuing some
timing, because this is
how I produce the times that are
spit out in the UI so we
can see how long these
things take.
We then decode the resource, and
that will either reuse the
bitmap or not, depending on
whether we set the bitmap
parameter above.
And then we set the new image
bitmap in the image view.
Finally, we get the final
time that it took and
display that in the UI.
And that's it.
Not very hard to use, but
definitely worth using.
Especially if you're in the case
where you're constantly
loading in new bitmaps and those
bitmaps are the same
size as other bitmaps that
you're now done with.
This basically allows a garbage
collector get out of
the way, because there's nothing
to collect if you're
loading the new bitmap into
the place of the old one.
So check out bitmap options,
in particular inBitmap.
And save some grief over garbage
collection times.
Thanks.